le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
père de la musique jouer d'un instrument
et pourquoi pas en faire son métier
c'est le rêve de Frank
mais pour apprendre à jouer d'un
instrument il faut prendre des cours
pendant plusieurs années il faut
investir dans son instrument devenir
musicien ça peut être très coûteux alors
comment accomplir son rêve lorsqu'on est
issu d'une famille modeste comment allez
au bout de ses ambitions on en parle
maintenant dans lien social
Franck a 11 ans il vit avec ses parents
et son frère dans le quartier du bas de
la rivière c'est un jeune garçon épanoui
et comme tous les enfants Franck à aarev
devenir un jour un musicien
professionnel
en regardant des musiciens à la télé en
écoutant de la musique orageux j'ai
voulu devenir musicien
pour accomplir son rêve Franck doit
prendre des cours pour devenir un vrai
virtuose et viser une carrière
professionnelle ça peut prendre des
années et puis il faut investir dans un
instrument pour beaucoup de familles à
la Réunion cette passion représente un
budget difficile voire impossible à
assumer Frank a de la chance son
instrument il l'a c'est une trompette et
il en est fier il prend des cours
collectifs de musique et fait même
partie d'une petite troupe
il y avait une madame et un monsieur qui
est venu dans la classe
ils ont dit comme ça
que en 6e il y avait une classe en
caisse et j'étais intéressé
et ensuite j'ai choisi la tromper
dans son quartier au collège redley
Franck a la chance de pouvoir faire
vivre sa passion sa classe bénéficie
d'heures de musique supplémentaire les
méthodes pédagogiques sont adaptées pour
encourager les élèves à s'investir dans
la musique tout est fait pour que ces
enfants évoluent le mieux possible dans
un univers qui les motive alors cette
classe
bénéficie d'heures de musique
supplémentaire par rapport à un emploi
du temps normal d'une classe de 6e
l'apprentissage n'est pas exactement
identique à ce que
ce qui pourrait travailler à l'école de
musique c'est à dire que l'enfant
pratique l'instrument avant même de
connaître la lecture et l'écriture de la
musique alors les instruments qui sont
mis à disposition par la Fédération
Musicale de la Réunion et avec l'aide
bien entendu du conseil général sont des
instruments assez coûteux voire très
coûteux pour certaines d'entre eux et la
plupart des familles des enfants qui
bénéficient du projet n'aurait pas
forcément accès à ces instruments là
d'autant que les cours en école de
musique ou en conservatoire
est en payant ici le projet est
entièrement gratuit
la majorité des enfants de cette classe
bénéficient de cours de musique depuis
le début de l'année avant il n'avait
jamais eu la chance de toucher de telles
instruments et au bout de quelques mois
ils ont même pu monter sur scène devant
un public une expérience une espérée
nous nous sommes fiers de nos jeunes qui
ne sont partis de d'aucune culture
musicale qui commence à l'entrée de la
sixième les débuts ont été très
difficiles mais nous sommes fiers d'eux
puisqu'ils ont quand même fait quelques
petits concerts depuis pour la fin de
l'année pour le lors du carnaval c'est
vrai que c'est un travail relativement
soutenu qu'on leur demande mais ils s'en
sortent pas trop mal à la Réunion la
musique a toujours occupé une grande
place dans le cœur des Réunionnais et
beaucoup de jeunes ont de grandes
facilités dans ce domaine c'est pour
cette raison que le Conseil Général
apporte un soutien actif à ce programme
chaque année un budget est consacré à
l'achat d'instruments qui seraient
inaccessible pour beaucoup de familles
une opportunité formidable pour les
enfants de cette classe ils sont bien
conscients que la route est encore
longue pour devenir musicien
professionnel mais avec ses cours
supplémentaires et les instruments
qu'ils peuvent enfin toucher ils savent
aussi que leurs rêves est à leur portée
il ne leur reste qu'à travailler pour y
parvenir ils y sont prêts
à la maison et ben j'ai commencé à faire
Franck encouragé par sa famille et son
entourage pourra peut-être devenir un
trompettiste renommé il a en tout cas
saisi sa chance et fera tout pour vivre
de sa passion et pourquoi pas plus tard
être un nouvel ambassadeur de la réunion
sur des scènes lointaines
à son âge tous les rêves sont permis
vous je voudrais devenir un grand
musicien professionnel
peut-être le numéro 1
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais